[Music]
the loud house is one of the most
popular modern Nickelodeon cartoons out
there but what would happen if these
modern characters would get an anime or
a manga makeover stay tuned to see a
Sailor Moon inspired illustration
created by the loud house's storyboard
artists don't forget to hit that
notification bell to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun now
let's check out the loud house
characters as manga and anime Lisa loud
let's start with the one and only Lisa
loud as the youngest character on the
show you think Lisa wouldn't have as
much personality as the rest of her
siblings but truth be told she's pretty
awesome this manga version of Lisa
belongs to the talented calippo art from
deviantART who did an awesome job at
showing us what she looked like as a
manga character and it's one of the only
times we can actually see Lisa as a much
taller character although to be fair
there's nothing wrong with the adorable
short Lisa either but even tall Lisa is
a total science nerd of course she would
be we wouldn't have her any other way
and of course she's wearing her
signature sweater we don't even need to
see it in full color to know it'll be
the Lisa version of green Laurie loud
next is the one and only Laurie loud as
the oldest child Laurie has the
advantage of being totally bossy and
truth be told we can't blame her living
with ten other siblings is pretty
intense and everyone deserves some time
out we bet that this is how her attitude
looks like to her fellow siblings check
out deviant arts JCM to illustration
from Laurie or as the artist calls her
captain glory first of all she looks
totally awesome and second of all her
hair looks so cool when it's drawn in a
realistic way and third of all she's
totally rockin that outfit isn't she
let's just hope she's not too harsh on
her siblings with her cast and attitude
although we all know that she probably
will be again how can you blame her when
she had to put up with so many kids for
so many years
Lola loud Lola is definitely one of our
favorite characters sure she's a little
bit of a diva but she reminds us of a
cartoon version of honey boo boo
seriously if Alana Thompson ever got her
own cartoon character it would be Lola
loud but here's Steven darts JCM too
strong of Lola doesn't she look awesome
of course she's still a little princess
which isn't really surprising
we're digging that outfit
and her tiara the artist even kept down
her front tooth which is missing in the
original version too speaking of the
original version Lola is also the
typical glass lady her and Lauri
definitely deserved more moments
together not really sure what's
happening with that slightly shy and
awkward pose though you have to admit
she's still pretty adorable crazy
lynnie loud Lennie might be the second
oldest kid but she's a complete opposite
to her sister Lori she's much more
caring and relaxed when it comes to her
siblings and she definitely doesn't have
the same attitude she's all into fashion
and she always makes sure she looks good
this is exactly how deviantART JCM to
portrayed her - check her out she looks
pretty awesome it's obvious that she's
still the same fashionista but doesn't
this version of her original dress look
way better and of course she still has
her iconic white sunglasses on she
wouldn't be winning if she didn't the
artist named her Linna soar and let's be
honest she is pretty roarsome
this illustration is too adorable and it
definitely portrays Lennie as the
playful character she is on the show
loon aloud and how could we possibly
forget about the one and only Luna the
rock chick of the family has a soft spot
in our hearts we just love that she's
educating kids on old-school rock when
she hums her songs and uses her rock
puns she's an absolutely perfect
character JCM - from deviantART showed
us what she looked like as an awesome
anime and manga character doesn't she
look perfect
of course she's still rocking out and
we're totally digging that realistic
haircut out of all loud kids we
definitely want to sport Lunas
accessories don't they just look awesome
loving those bracelets girl she's
definitely one of those characters you
fall in love with over time and fully
accept the fact that her voice sometimes
goes into his strange British accents
for no apparent reason
Lincoln loud and how could we possibly
forget about the star of the show as it
basically talks about his life in a
large family but get ready because the
anime version of Lincoln looks way
cooler than you could ever imagine
this image belongs to the talented Mara
whose tumblr is marathon and you should
definitely check it out if you need some
inspiration for your drawings this
version of Lincoln is actually so
handsome we'll probably never see
what Lincoln looks like when he's all
grown up but honestly this puts us a
pretty good indication
we're totally here for it he definitely
looks slightly shy as one would after
they spend most of their lifetime living
under the same roof as his ten
strong-willed sisters you might want to
run
Lucey loud stick around to check out
some anime interactions between your fav
loud house characters but first let's
check out what Lucy would look like as
an anime Lucy is one of those underrated
characters that's actually pretty funny
of course she might scare little kids
watching the show but we feel like she
might just be the most relatable of them
all check out deviant arts JC into
version of Lucy as an anime character
wait
is that a smile we see are we sure this
is actually Lucy either way her hair
looks totally awesome and she looks like
she's having fun it's rare to see you
Lucy show an emotion other than well
being serious so let's just enjoy this
moment because it most likely will never
happen again
side mcbride if you're a loyal
subscriber you know we absolutely love
the loud house but you might also know
we don't talk about Clyde much cried is
just one of those neighborhood kids you
can't help but love sure his obsession
with Lorri might be a little bit weird
but hey we've all had crushes on
neighbors kids before so we can't really
blame them here's deviant arts Michel
scipios illustration of a slightly more
realistic version of Clyde what do you
think we're giving it a thumbs up and by
the looks of it Clyde likes the way he
looks too who knows maybe Laurie might
dig his new look and finally ditch Bobby
do you think Clyde will ever succeed
with his obsession with Laurie let us
know in the comments Lana and Lola so
let's check out these two troublemakers
together
truth be told these twins couldn't be
more opposite if they tried it's just
hard to believe they're twins
considering they're totally opposite
personalities but that's what makes them
so awesome here they are in a slightly
different version created by Mike and
Mel from deviantART they might be total
opposites but they still know how to
work together we absolutely love it
we're not sure what's going on but we
have a feeling this will be yet another
adventure for these two let's just hope
they stay out of trouble and bring along
someone sensible to guide them like
Lincoln let's be honest these
you are definitely not the most
independent cartoon characters you know
but that's what makes them so special
Lincoln and Lily so let's talk about one
of the cutest friendships in the loud
house we all know parents don't really
do much in cartoons and they really
hardly do anything in the loud house
that's precisely why Lincoln's the one
taking care of his youngest sister Lily
but their friendship is absolutely
adorable this image belongs to dark
Meera MA 23 from tumbler and it's the
cutest thing you've ever seen
it's exactly what happens on the actual
show Lincoln just always takes care of
Lily he's totally trying to read her a
book while she's messing around and not
paying attention as most babies do you
have to admit that Lincoln's always
doing a good job with Lily come to think
of it he's always kind and caring toward
everyone in the loud house isn't he too
bad he doesn't always get the same
attitude back don't you Jer post those
Lula and Luanne aren't these two a
slightly unusual couple we don't often
see Luna and LuAnn together even though
their names are very similar but not
only that they have the same type of
personalities that would definitely get
along but since Luanne tends to take her
jokes away too far sometimes Luna just
needs a chill moment this image belongs
to Mike and Nell from deviantART who
really did an awesome job at portraying
these two as anime characters they look
like they're having so much fun we
definitely deserve to have more Luna and
LuAnn moments together because look how
awesome they'd be what do you think are
these two a perfect sibling match or
what we do have a feeling they get tired
of each other real quick though Lincoln
and Lynn Lynn and Lincoln have a very
complicated relationship since Lynne is
so competitive and Lincoln so caring
it's always hard for these two to make
sense of each other even deke at 98 from
deviantART think so check out this
awesome illustration of what Lincoln and
Lynn would look like with superpowers
Lynn's powers are clearly fire-related
but Lincoln just looks awesome it really
does represent their relationship
they're a complete opposite of each
other
we'd love to actually see their
superpowers on the show though don't
worry we have more superpower pictures
to show you later on too so make sure
you keep on watching but for real we
can't get over how cool it is to see
these two working together it's a rare
moment which is why it makes it so much
more special Lenny and Laurie speaking
of total opposites it's hard to imagine
these two getting along
- there seems to be a mutual respect
between them since they're the older
siblings but they definitely could have
a lot more interactions deviantART
artists letti - Excel shows us how it
would look if they'd be even closer
friends isn't this just adorable and
they totally look like their original
versions - we can actually really see
these two in a proper anime they'd be
the best characters ever just look at
how friendly they are with each other
but we do have a feeling Laurie is
holding her phone in her other hands
because let's be honest that girl can't
get off her phone like ever you have to
admit that this is one of the cutest
photos ever did everyone I texted Bobby
a series of romantic emojis Lola and
Lincoln we're not sure who created this
gif but whoever did it really deserves a
medal because this is a pretty adorable
interaction between Lincoln and Lola we
all know that Lola the diva often gets
help from Lincoln when it comes to her
pageant stuff seriously where are these
kids parents but since they're not there
it means we can get tons of adorable
interactions this is so cute
Lincoln seems to struggle to understand
what he's actually doing but it looks
like lil is actually appreciating it
it's quite bizarre seeing her this happy
and not freaked out but who knows maybe
her anime versions have a lot less
attitude than her original self
Lola's and Lincoln's relationship is
definitely one of those that is a
pleasant surprise you just wouldn't
assume these two would get along so well
all of them get ready because this
illustration is pretty special
it belongs to Jordin Rosato who's
actually the loud houses storyboard
artist yep she's the one that draws out
all loud house animations how cool is
that but because she's a fan of Sailor
Moon she decided to create the loud
house characters as Sailor Moon
characters and she even added Lily don't
they look awesome with their cute
superpowers check out Lucy with her
power stands and lisas floating with the
same slightly annoyed look she always
has these are absolutely perfect and you
can totally tell they actually come from
a person who draws these characters on
the actual show now we just need to
convince the loud house to have an
episode where the characters actually do
get superpowers let's be honest that
would be absolutely amazing and that's
it for our video thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]